foreign
is one of your
Sports in the sort of decathlon of of
deal making
that is the craft one of the crafts
you've mastered
this is going to seem like a lazy
question but I'm going to ask because
it'll be on the mind of a lot of people
listening
for someone who wanted to become a
skilled negotiator
would you have any recommendations in
terms of resources approaches
common beliefs that are actually very
unhelpful anything at all for somebody
who wants to develop their ability to
negotiate well
of course
and it's probably the opposite of what
people believe or instinctively would do
which is usually the answer by the way
so I would say like 90 of time everyone
focuses on what is important to them and
what
we or what you say
it's irrelevant
all that matters is how it lands to the
other person
it's a life
in order to understand how something
will land to other person you have to
meet them where they are
you can put yourself in their shoes
once you put yourself in someone else's
shoes then you don't have to do what
they say in a negotiation they have to
at least start with that understanding
and then go back to what's most
important to you from there and then you
have a fair
understanding of what that negotiation
is going to look like
but if you just start like throwing your
words against the wall
is never going to end well and you're
going to be very frustrated it'll be
temper tantrums and so on I I kind of
make it the best analogy I can think of
is when you're in a huddle about to
throw a pass in a football game
and you have figured out you're going to
throw a post pattern in the Huddle and
you've thought about in that huddle
if you
you know say hi play goes and you throw
the post pattern play
but you haven't looked at actually what
happened in the field and the receiver
had to go in a different direction
you need to meet that receiver where
they are
your post pattern play is irrelevant
it's only relevant to your formation at
the beginning
but it's not relevant to actually where
the ball is going to go in the end
because what happened on the field is
much more important so like you have to
do the preparation work and have to have
a sense of what you think is proper and
right from your perspective but you also
have to understand what will be the
scenarios that will be important to them
and then the middle ground approach was
too often used it's not that it's just
starting from understanding both Vantage
points it's the same kind of skill set
as saying before I put a Buy on
something I have to also reject the cell
you know you have to um be comfortable
in an unknown position before you can
adequately argue for your for what's
important to you and then in a trusted
relationship which is the only way to
negotiate with a trusted relationship
you're going to get down to things that
are really important and things that are
not really that important and to be able
to be comfortable saying that like okay
if I listed these three things please
rank in order for me
what's most important to you and what
you really don't need that will give me
a little bit more room to come back to
something that I think we could work
with because that shows that you'll be
able to give up something to get
something which is obviously Hallmark to
any transaction
now that's a good negotiation there are
tactics above that so sometimes in order
to get to someone that you need you may
ask for things that you don't really
want just to settle back in
to something
that is a discount to that that you only
would do that if if you feel like the
other person is doing the same thing so
it all goes back to trust
and that trust is not about one person
trusting another it's that different
phases of the negotiation that trust
picks up so at the beginning of a
negotiation it may be less trustworthy
than at the end when things are really
coming to the Finish Line when you can
see the light of day that things start
to pick up towards the trust so you have
to see kind of when you complain those
different tactics but then today it's
kind of putting your seeing people where
they are I think it's really important
without giving up what you really need
let's explore that a bit so seeing
people where they are you gave the
football
metaphor
could you describe
an actual deal
situation or process it could be real it
could be anonymized it could be
hypothetical but just to walk us through
a concrete
case study of what that
looks like knowing the other side since
you led with that in your answer could
you perhaps just walk us through an
example
all the deals that we work on that are
public
company deals end up being
filed publicly with the play-by-play of
the deal no one likes to read legal
documents
but the fun part of the legal document
is the play-by-play of the deal if
people are interested in the
step-by-step of how a deal works because
while we're doing the deal we're very
aware of the fact that it will be filed
publicly so it's not like you're pulling
fast ones because
either it's going to be disclosed how
you're doing what you're doing
so you have to be truthful there's no
concept of like lying at a deal because
it will all be uncovered later if you
want to be in the business the next day
so that's called the proxy statement and
that one section is
written up by lawyers that actually
recount the deal did not know that yeah
so what I'm going to say is public
information you know when we did the
transaction of selling MGM Studios to
Amazon
which is the only example of a Content
company being sold to a technology
company today
there was an impasse between the buyer
and the seller that went on for a while
and the the deal ended up being worth
around 8.5 billion dollars
but for months
Amazon will not go above 8 billion
and MGM
and the owners of MGM so we are not
selling below nine billion dollars hell
of high water
and so we were at an eight to nine
billion dollar bid ask for months
to the point where the deal could have
gone away like a bit you know one hand
you're close the other hand nothing's
happening
so finally the chairman of MGM who was
really dear friend
you know calls me and says like I'm
ready to like what do you think I'm
ready to unlock this Gap
and I knew Amazon very well enough to
know that they were thinking because
this Gap was going on for so long that
the owner of MGM and the chairman
in their mind they're thinking didn't
really want to sell
so they're thinking that 9 billion was
just basically saying I don't really
want to sell
but I knew that was not to be the case
so
the owner and chairman of MGM said to me
um I give you my proxy
to go in there
and break the logic
and so I did when I went to call the
Amazon executive
I said okay we're ready to negotiate now
they said well there's nothing to
negotiate you know they're at nine
billion you know we're at 8 billion and
we're not moving I said
okay I said well and they're not even
really selling the company I said well
what if I told you that they were
selling the company he said well how
would I know I said well
I'll in good faith
speak on behalf of the chairman and give
you a new offer
that will
yield a bit under the condition
that you respond to me within 24 hours
with a counter offer then we'll get the
ball rolling
so I get also the feedback back to the
chairman
that you're serious about dealing
meaning that if I could speak
for a principal you have to speak
also that you want to get something done
but I'm not going to move unless you're
gonna move and I need to know that
you're gonna move
and that was trust because they took a
risk that I could represent the owners
of MGM
and uh
they said um okay what do you got I said
I think we should split the difference
and go right to it but it has to go fast
and you have to get back to me right
away
and I did
and if they didn't
and in those 48 hours there's a lot of
emotion you know but they did get back
and I moved very very fast from there